Le mur d’Hadrien, c’est la plus célèbre frontière
de l’Empire romain. Situé dans le nord de
l’Angleterre, tout près de la frontière avec
l’Ecosse, il traverse l’île de Grande-Bretagne
d’est en ouest, de la mer du Nord à la mer
d’Irlande.
Symbole absolu de la conquête romaine,
ultime frontière de l’Empire, il déroule
ses vestiges au milieu des landes balayées
par les vents.
Aujourd'hui royaume des moutons, la
région était dans l’Antiquité, peuplée de soldats.
Seuls dans une tour ou avec quelques frères
d’armes dans un fort, ils guettaient le nord et
une improbable attaque d’envahisseurs du bout
du monde.
A mille lieues de la Méditerranée, transis de froid et accablés par les pluies
quotidiennes ou presque, leur destin a inspiré
des chansons et des poèmes, bien aidé par la
nostalgie qu’inspire cette muraille solitaire.
Pas insensible à cet imaginaire,
j’ai moi-même voulu aller voir ça,
et vous me connaissez, j’ai emmené ma caméra.
Le sud de la Grande-Bretagne, que les Romains
nomment Britannia, a été conquis au premier
siècle après J.-C. En l’an 43, l’empereur
Claude envoie quatre légions de l’autre côté
de la Manche. De nombreux épisodes de révoltes
et de répressions sanglantes plus tard, les
armées romaines entament la conquête de l’Ecosse.
Mais alors que la victoire est presque acquise,
le général Agricola est rappelé à Rome et ses
armées se replient vers le sud. Elles s’installent
sur une ligne suffisamment étroite pour être
défendue efficacement, ce qui va devenir le mur.
C’est ici qu’intervient Hadrien. Après les
grandes conquêtes de son prédécesseur Trajan,
Hadrien inaugure une ère plus défensive. L’Empire
romain est à son apogée, il fait plus de 5
millions de kilomètres carrés et poursuivre les
conquêtes s’avère difficile. Hadrien s’investit
donc activement dans la diplomatie avec les
peuples barbares pour sécuriser les confins
de l'Empire et il abandonne même quelques
provinces lointaines comme la Mésopotamie.
Surtout, il lance de grands travaux sur les
tronçons les plus exposés des frontières.
Après l’Afrique et la Germanie, il se rend sur
l’île de Bretagne. C’est là qu’il ordonne la
construction d’un dispositif totalement
inédit qui gardera son nom : une ligne
de fortification de 117 kilomètres entre le
fond du golfe de Solway et l’embouchure de laTyne.
Nulle part ailleurs Rome n’érigera
un tel dispositif de défense. Hadrien,
qui a lui-même vécu aux côtés de l’armée, a
sans doute eu pitié de ses hommes, exposés aux
incessantes embuscades des tribus insoumises
qui allaient et venaient en toute liberté.
Il faut donc faire vite. Dans sa première phase,
le mur est construit en mottes de terre coupées
à la bêche et empilées par les légionnaires,
qui sont réquisitionnés pour l’occasion. Ils
en ont l’habitude, les travaux de maçonnerie
ou de terrassement font partie du métier. A
l’avant du mur, le fossé d’où est extraite la
terre forme lui aussi un obstacle important.
Achevée en très peu de temps, cette
première construction n’est pas
définitive. Dans une deuxième phase, le
mur est consolidé. A la mode romaine,
un parement en pierre est appliqué
sur un ouvrage d’opus caementicium,
pierres et gravats indistinctement coulés dans
le mortier. Les fondations du mur montrent une
épaisseur de trois mètres mais l’élévation
était sans doute plus étroite. Au sommet,
il faut imaginer un petit chemin de patrouille et
peut-être un parapet en bois avec des créneaux.
Cette fortification peut passer pour un aveu de
faiblesse de Rome, se barricadant car n’ayant pas
su vaincre, pourtant ce mur massif, continu et
bien gardé, adressait tout de même aux barbares
un avertissement très explicite. Avec ses 4 ou
5 mètres de hauteur et ses pierres blanchies à
la chaux, le rempart tranchait nettement
avec le paysage des landes britanniques.
D’autant que le mur était complété par des fortins
qu’on appelle les milecastles. Régulièrement
espacés de mille pas, soit 1481 mètres, ils
sont la rationalité romaine dans sa plus pure
expression. En tout, il y a donc 80 petits
châteaux, qui accueillaient chacun quelques
dizaines d’hommes. Ici l’un d’eux, le milecastle
n°39 livre encore des vestiges des bâtiments
internes, entrepôts et maisons qui ont abrité
pendant plusieurs siècles les soldats du mur.
Soldats auxiliaires d’un statut inférieur
aux légionnaires puisqu’ils n'étaient pas
citoyens romains, ils étaient aussi moins payés
et moins équipés que leurs compagnons d’armes,
stationnés plus au sud. Originaires
d’Espagne et de Gaule notamment,
ils sont de plus en plus recrutés sur
place avec la romanisation de l’île.
En plus des travaux d’entretien du mur, ils
s’occupent aussi des vaches et des troupeaux
de moutons qui leur fournissent la viande et
la laine indispensable pour affronter l’hiver.
Entre deux fortins comme celui-ci, deux tours
de guet étaient érigées et offraient une vue
dégagée dans toutes les directions.
En parallèle, une route pavée suivait
le dispositif et permettait de manœuvrer des
troupes rapidement. A l’arrière de la route,
côté romain donc, un autre fossé est creusé, le
vallum. Profond de trois mètres et large de six,
il était pensé pour ralentir les maraudeurs
cherchant à repartir dans l’autre sens, ou pour
se protéger de la tribu des Brigantes, installée
en territoire romain, mais dont la loyauté
était très relative. On aperçoit encore les
vestiges de ce large fossé ici près de Cawburn.
Enfin, un réseau de plus grands forts,
espacés d’environ onze kilomètres, venait
renforcer l’ensemble. Ils devaient accueillir
l’effectif d’une cohorte, soit environ 500
hommes. Certains d’entre eux sont encore bien
conservés, comme ici, celui de Vindolanda.
Équipés de greniers, de fours, d’une infirmerie,
d’ateliers d’artisanat, d’écuries, de petits
temples et d’un quartier général, ils révèlent
en détail le quotidien des soldats du mur.
A l’extérieur du camp, les habitants des
environs construisent aussi des boutiques,
des tavernes et des bordels, pour extorquer aux
militaires les quelques deniers de leur solde.
De petites agglomérations voient ainsi le jour et
les vétérans qui ont pris des épouses sur place
construisent souvent leur maison à proximité
du mur où ils ont vécu pendant des années.
A Housesteads, le fort est directement collé
au mur, au sommet d’une colline. Il offre
une vue imprenable sur la lande au nord. Les
archéologues y ont mis au jour de vastes écuries,
indispensables pour intervenir rapidement
en cas d’attaque sur le mur. Les latrines,
remarquablement conservées, sont installées à
l’angle sud-est du camp, à l’écart des logements.
Le fort de Chester est lui positionné
stratégiquement sur la rivière North Tyne. La
porte Est ouvrait directement sur un pont
de pierre, contrôlant encore une fois les
circulations. La maison du commandant avec son
vaste portique pavé était installée en plein
centre du camp. Autour, les logements
des soldats sont bien plus étroits.
Avec son rempart continu, ses garnisons et
ses forteresses, le mur d’Hadrien était un
dispositif de défense exceptionnel, au sens
propre. C’est un cas unique. C’est la réalité
géographique de la Grande-Bretagne, avec ses
obstacles naturels facilement exploitables,
qui a suscité une réponse de ce type au conquérant
romain. Ailleurs, les provinces frontalières de
l’empire sont dotées en légions mais elles ne
sont pas fortifiées à ce point-là. Il est de
toute façon impensable de construire, de
surveiller et d’entretenir un dispositif
comparable sur plusieurs milliers de kilomètres.
On s’appuie donc le plus souvent sur les fleuves,
les montagnes ou les déserts pour
constituer des remparts naturels.
L’objectif d’une telle présence militaire
sur le mur d’Hadrien n’était toutefois pas
d’ériger une barrière infranchissable, ce n’est
pas réaliste. Une troupe ennemie déterminée
pouvait facilement trouver un endroit mal gardé
et franchir la frontière. Le but recherché par
Hadrien était bien plus de contrôler des
checkpoints, et de percevoir des droits
de douane. On le voit dans les milecastles
puisqu’une porte du château ouvre au nord et
permet le passage, sous contrôle militaire.
Les sources textuelles ou archéologiques
ne livrent d’ailleurs que peu de traces
d’attaques sur le mur lui-même. On voit
au contraire se diffuser les objets romains parmi
les peuples frontaliers au nord. Partout sur les
frontières de l’empire, la présence de soldats,
disposant d’un bon pouvoir d’achat et recevant
du ravitaillement de l’Etat, stimule l’économie
locale. Le mur d’Hadrien n’échappe pas à la règle.
Empêcher une armée hostile de franchir
la frontière de l’Empire étant de toute
façon impossible, le plus important, c’est
de l’arrêter rapidement. Des feux allumés
sur les tours disposées le long de la route
d’Eboracum, aujourd’hui la ville d’York,
permettaient d’appeler en renfort la VIe
légion qui y était stationnée, une centaine
de kilomètres plus au sud. Le meilleur atout
pour la défense de l’Empire reste finalement
d’entretenir un réseau routier en bon état. Pour
Rome, la frontière c’est avant tout la route.
C’est pour cette raison qu’on l’appelait
limes. Ce terme, qui a donné notre “limite”,
est souvent utilisé pour désigner tout le
système de fortification, mais en réalité,
il désigne à l’origine le chemin qui borde un
champ et qui fait office de démarcation sur le
cadastre. Dans le vocabulaire militaire,
le limes, c’est la route des patrouilles,
qui symbolise aussi la frontière
entre le monde barbare et civilisé.
A la mort d’Hadrien, en 138 après J.-C.,
son successeur Antonin fait préparer une
expédition vers le nord de l’île pour occuper
une ligne de défense encore plus courte,
entre l’embouchure de la Clyde et du
Forth, près de Glasgow et Edimbourg.
Un nouveau mur est donc bâti en terre et bois
en 142, c’est le mur d’Antonin. Mais trop proche
des Highlands écossais, cette nouvelle frontière
expose l’armée romaine aux attaques incessantes
des tribus locales. Douze ans seulement après sa
construction, le nouveau rempart est abandonné,
l’armée se replie, retour sur le mur d’Hadrien.
Les siècles suivants sont marqués par les
révoltes et les guerres civiles, et Britannia
n’est plus une priorité pour Rome. Toutefois,
l’Empire s’accroche. Les empereurs et généraux qui
se rendent sur le mur d’Hadrien constatent qu’il
tombe en lambeaux et lancent à plusieurs reprises
des travaux de rénovation : Septime Sévère en 208,
Constance Chlore en 296, et enfin Théodose en 368.
Mais cette restauration du mur est la dernière.
En 410, l’empereur Honorius décide purement
et simplement d’abandonner l’île de Bretagne.
Les Wisigoths viennent de piller Rome,
et les légions bretonnes sont rappelées
sur le continent. Tant pis pour Britannia.
Du jour au lendemain, les soldes ne sont
plus payées et le ravitaillement n’arrive
plus. On imagine le désarroi de ceux qui ont
voué leur vie à Rome et sacrifié plusieurs
décennies de leur vie à patrouiller sur le
mur dans la solitude et les pluies glaciales.
Subitement renvoyés par une missive impériale,
les soldats doivent quitter leurs garnisons et
retourner à la vie civile. N’ayant rien connu
d’autre que la vie militaire, certains s’engagent
comme mercenaires. Les étrangers tentent de
regagner leurs provinces d’origine et d’autres
restent à proximité pour tenter une reconversion.
Les agglomérations qui se sont développées
au bord des camps perdurent donc pendant
un temps. Les artisans et les marchands y sont
établis depuis longtemps, mais sans la présence
de l’armée, les débouchés disparaissent. Les
fortifications tombent à nouveau en lambeaux,
définitivement cette fois. Les fossés se
comblent et les pierres sont réemployées
pour construire des églises ou des
maisons. C’est la fin du mur d’Hadrien.
S’ils ont plié bagage il y a mille six cents
ans, les Romains ont tout de même laissé un
peu de Méditerranée dans le paysage. Au pied
du mur, au milieu des vaches Galloway avec
leur épaisse toison, pousse aujourd’hui
un érable sycomore. Veilleur solitaire,
perdu loin du continent, il est comme
un souvenir de cette antique présence.